hello everybody hope they are good first
of all I want to say thank you for all
your messages support in the content I'm
very happy about that and yes we're
having fun with the charts but of course
you have even more fun when you consider
the price action goes in our favor and
the projections are getting completed
so just to give you some context
um remember that we established that we
can range we were expecting a false move
on Monday and because we had the week to
the downside it is going to be our final
Target let's call it like that okay for
Monday's first move we were expecting a
pump into resistance or resistance was
the 15 minute 40 time frame and the 15
in the daily time frame okay this is the
four hour and this is the daily time
frame
um you can see the you know we perfectly
went into this Zone and then got
rejected also in this day on Monday uh
we zoomed in in the one hour time frame
and we expected also um stop hunting the
New York session we saw that happening
and then at boom during the day since
then back into this liquidity pool over
here that you can see that it got failed
okay so all good
now when we see a false move on Monday I
call it a false move because usually
what happens is that during the rest of
the week the trend goes into the
opposite direction okay so that means
that if we've had a false movement to
the upside we're expecting that the rest
of the week we could see a trend to the
downside okay and that would be towards
this week now I don't know if this is
going to happen or not today is I think
today is Wednesday okay so this is very
important
because the weekly psychological pattern
usually is Monday is for this move well
let me explain to you very quickly here
you have
the weekend range and then you can see
Monday's first moved up to the opposite
of the downside let's do it to the
upside then you can see the week going
into the opposite direction okay so
that's uh after the first move finished
I was uh in the New York City on Monday
the stop hunt and then from then we can
see go to the downside and then on
Thursday
sometimes on Wednesday but usually
sometimes that you can see some kind of
reversal okay and that can take you
sometimes back into the weekend range or
very close to it so my via is you know
to be running shorts
until probably tomorrow okay so by
tomorrow I would like between today and
tomorrow that they hit this week
okay then in this week if if this
happens by today or tomorrow then I'm
gonna close my shorts and I'm gonna try
to switch to a long okay to a scalp long
position
um again I don't know I don't have a
crystal ball I don't even want to see
this pattern playing out exactly like
that this week some weeks play out
different we might see today for example
some sideways and maybe tomorrow which
is something like this who knows okay
but of course we're going with the cycle
and we're expecting
that between today and tomorrow
hopefully they can fill this week then
we can close all Longs okay and then we
can see some kind of uh long scalp
opportunity okay maybe back here to
around 26 600 so that's what I'm that's
what I'm keeping an eye on for now okay
now I would like to go into the order
book to see where the liquid it is is
the liquidity to the downside or to the
upside
okay write another book and we can see
that the liquidities to the downside
okay there is quality liquidity at 26
500 and of course at 26 000 because it's
a round number and also if you notice in
matches with the week what a coincidence
right
um now you have to understand that the
other book includes everything okay it
includes buy and sell limit orders stop
losses and liquidations because the stop
losses and liquidations are also limit
order so here includes everything it's
kind of like a good thing but also a bad
thing because you cannot distinguish it
doesn't tell you what each thing is okay
it doesn't tell you if 26 000 are by
limit orders or if they are stop losses
or liquidations it doesn't tell you okay
you have to figure it out in another way
in my case I go to high blood Capital
into the chart because in high low
capital I can see the liquidations and
in the chart I can see where for example
the stop losses can be okay okay but now
obviously I can see that 26 000 will
have the week so all those orders are
because of that week so that's an
interesting Zone in the chart okay so in
principle the other book is giving us
Confluence that price could go down
let's have a look at the dollar Index
because I know that it's moving nicely
let's have a look uh I mean we drew this
W pattern we've been talking about it
for a month I think that the first or
the second YouTube video that I uploaded
we were talking about this formation in
the dollar Index and you can see that it
seems that it might be playing out okay
it's looking pretty bullish for the
dollar uh let me tell you what I think
of this price action over here but so
far what I can see is that we have a big
drop we found a bottom then a retrace
towards the daily 50ma we actually went
above it but you can see that we failed
to test it as support So price went
again to these lows what happened here
is very interesting and it's pretty
bullish because you can see that they
actually swap the lows okay you're gonna
be able to see here
is trapping Traders into believing that
price will continue to go lower okay so
Traders here are gonna place also limit
shorts okay because I want to be
breakout Traders I want to think okay if
price breaks below this previous low
then we're losing support and we're
gonna go lower so what the market does
instead is they sweep the lows and they
push price higher
and you can see it here very well okay
uh now it seems that we are again above
the daily 50ma and yesterday it was to
be honest actually yesterday and on
Monday too
um we tested our support and now prices
going higher so this is looking in my
opinion valuable is for the index um I
think
um this W formation is looking uh quite
likely okay when the dxy goes up Bitcoin
goes down okay
um when the dollar Index goes goes down
Bitcoin is gonna go up so as long as the
dollar Index keeps pushing up okay
Bitcoin is not gonna do well so this is
why I think you should keep an eye on
this chart
um of course the key here my opinion is
the daily 50ma as long as we're above it
then you know we're gonna continue
testing a support keep pressing pies up
and so on
we are back in the Bitcoin chart and I
want to remind you that this is not
Financial advice okay it's just the
opinions of a random Trader I do this
for myself in a daily basis because I
have to prepare the setups uh for me for
the day and the only difference is that
I'm just sharing my thoughts with you
guys here in Twitter and on YouTube okay
that's that's the realities you are at
the end of the day responsible of your
own trades you shouldn't follow
anybody straight this video should only
be uh Confluence or for educational
purposes but what I can favor this week
but what I'm hoping for is that we see
at least the 50 of the week getting
filled why because we have the
Confluence in the order book we saw a
lot of liquidity at 26 000 okay and also
the dollar Index is going up okay so as
long as it continues gonna go down of
course you can see now that was the day
time for another index if you're going
to the one hour time frame maybe we see
some kind of retreating dollar Index and
that can make Bitcoin you know maybe
pushing all the way into the one hour or
the 4r50ma around 27 100 again why not
but this week is still a very
interesting zone so I think we're still
gonna come here sooner or later okay or
at least that's what I think
um now let me take you to the weekly
time frame really quickly okay
let me remove this
and the daily 50ma so now what you can
see here is that we have the weekly
50ma uh 25 700 okay the week is also at
25 800 so that's pretty much the same
place and you also have you go to the
Daily time frame okay you have a very
interesting Zone
here
okay
um that's at 25
000 200. the currency again the price
goes a little here we see a sell-off
price goes again here sell off and we
haven't tested it as support yet uh so
why not you have a lot of different uh
Confluence between 25 200 and uh 25 800
okay so that would be this Zone over
here I think it's very likely the price
comes back to this Zone
um that is at least what I'm what I
think is it might happen and the fifty
percent of the week
I think it's uh for sure
um that's around twenty six thousand
fifty I think we said or 26 066 uh by
this I mean this one is still between 25
200 and 25 800 you have a lot of
Confluence to believe that that's an
interesting Zone in the chart for price
to go back to okay uh then from here you
can even see a push you know maybe even
go above this highs or if not they're
gonna see price you know going down and
you have here quality of liquidity pools
if we mark them
this is a massive liquidity pool here
and that's between 23 800 and 20 500
that's an imbalance in the chart these
two candles okay
um so why not this is what I think at
the moment okay I think we should visit
probably this wide uh rectangle over
here
um then price will decide what to do
next from here okay either to see a push
and go above the previous highs or you
know we lose this this keys on here and
we're going towards this imbalance also
remember that in high blood capital in
the liquidation heat map
we have here a 22 400 a lot of
liquidations okay and that's in this
zone so I want you guys to think about
the chart of course guys thank you so
much for watching and I'll see you soon